and I met him at the door and then it
happened it shook the room I've never
been around anything like that before
I got a dad that really farts good
afternoon thank you for discovering the
Renaissance in sunny downtown how may I
direct your call
hi yeah um do you get to consume one
book a room to commemorate this
Cincinnati fart that happened last year
book a room to commemorate what I'm
sorry could you repeat that
the Cincinnati fart at our hotel there's
something called the Cincinnati fart
right sounds like you're familiar with
it a little bit yeah well I I went on
this river cruise and they had a really
big buffet and I was six months pregnant
so like I ate way more than I normally
would lasagna chicken pork broccoli
garlic mashed potatoes two helpings of
bread I had four desserts that day and
then I took a nap right after yeah I
mean after dinner I went back to the
room and you know she greeted me and I
was just expecting to have a normal
night but it was anything but normal
what did it sound like
and by the way catering wasn't that good
and that's why I farted so big the food
was garbage it was like a garbage buffet
and I ate every piece of garbage on the
table I mean me look at me I really had
some great parts in my life but nothing
like the Cincinnati part was legendary
the longest part I ever had in my entire
life
and it was amazing I mean that the
carpets changed color in that room paint
started appeal it was really really
disgusting oh my god you guys are so
disgusting
this isn't a tea fart was a legit 25
second plus fart I think the room still
smells I'd be surprised if it didn't
yeah that room does have this thing but
they do make me do my drains but it
still comes next I'm not sure what it is
it was like garbage on top of vomit on
top of this is the worst thing I've
ever smelled
people ask me Christina how can I far it
like you eat bad food it's just that
simple
I'm not your fart guru but I can tell
you what you do to help yourself you can
eat bad today let us not only remember
our fallen soldiers but let us also
remember the Cincinnati fart what was so
special about that room
the Cincinnati fart could you spell that
for me yeah F a r T like passing gas oh
okay what you want to bring forward sure
yeah this is 34 thank you yes